[Music]
and welcome back to Hannity German
Chancellor Angela Merkel is now saying
she supports Banning burkers in her
country saying quote wherever it's
legally possible now as we've been
reporting Germany has seen a massive
influx of refugees over the past several
years here now with reaction the
director of jihad watch Robert Spencer
and from the Islamic House of Wisdom
Imam Muhammad Ali alaki is with us um
let me ask you about some countries
where a lot of these immigrants are
coming from imom and that is if you come
from a country where men tell women how
to dress men tell women that they can't
drive men tell women whether they can go
to work or school men decide whether
they can travel abroad and you believe
that you can kill gays and lesbians for
being gay and lesbian and you can
persecute Christians and Jews if you
come from that country and you want to
come to America don't those values AR
those values obviously contradict the
Constitutional Democratic Republic
values of this country the answer is yes
right it it does it is the answer is yes
but you know Sean before we talk about
Germany and other countries let us talk
about our home put the order in our
house first in the last three days three
ladies not very far from your Station in
New York City they were attack and they
did not wear burka so it's not not about
it is it is about it is about racism and
Injustice and
islamophobia let talk about the real I
condemn anybody that would lash out at
somebody or make a judgment against
somebody based how they dress but that's
not my point if America which has very
limited available I'll call them slots
for people to come into the country if
you're coming from a country that where
you grow up under a culture and values
that directly contradict ours if it
that's a clash of cultures I to me it's
irreconcilable if you come
here country country is that thinking
you can tell women at a dress that's not
going to fly here that is wrong but
which country are you talking about now
which
country okay Saudi Arabia the UAE uh
Kuwait you know which country you want
to go tell tell your friend Trump why he
called King Salman as his first
listen you want to talk to Trump you
tell Trump I'm not your messenger you
tell them yourself but Robert Spencer
you've been studying this the bottom
line is there is a clash of cultures and
America has to consider whether or not
those people that we're bringing into
this country are bringing those let's
say Antiquated insane values with them
there's no doubt about it Sean that's
absolutely true and it's very important
the fact is that uh if there have been
attacks against women wearing hijab
that's reprehensible but the real
problem is attacks by Muslim
supremacists against women who are not
wearing hijab including right in Canada
a young girl named AXA parz she was
murdered by her father and brother for
not wearing hijab just a few years ago
this has happened elsewhere in America
and in Europe and these are the kinds of
values that are coming in where women
are essentially commodified devalued M
I'll
ask I got a question for we condemn if
such a thing happen we condemn that
that's wrong Imam Robert bringing up a
good point you're asking me which
countries treat women gays lesbians
Christians and Jews this way in the name
of your religion
you let me get my question my question
to you is are you going to speak out and
say sharel law as practiced in those
countries is abusive to those groups
abusive to women is it abusive of course
if
you if if you are talking about Shar in
Saudi Arabia of course that's not Shar
that is is
that
is anti-islamic I got videos of of gays
and lesbians being thrown off ruls in
Iran is that equally abusive in Iran at
least there is a democracy the the Jews
the Christians they have the
representative in the parliament for you
this is Sunni versus Shia this isn't
about what's right and wrong is what
Iran does an abuse towards women and
gays and lesbians yes or no there there
is no abuse to women and and and gain
Iran show me the evidence you want to
you want to trash the sunnis but not the
sh
no it is about truth it is about Justice
I don't care
about I'm talking about Justice I'm
talking about
Justice one St show me the evidence show
me the evidence where in in Iran there
is such a team is Iran the number one
state sponsor of Terror in the world
that is that is your version is your is
Iran a state sponsor of Terror yes or no
no I don't believe so no I don't believe
so that is Iran the terrorists in Iran
great Robert I think we got to the
bottom of it took a while Iran is the
leading State sponsor of Terror that's a
matter of demonstrable fact and it
supports his balah Hamas the Taliban
Al-Qaeda uh any Jihad there is Iran is
involved in some way how are you talking
about Iran now or you talking about tury
are you talking about Germany or you
talking about
now talk about
America talk about America all right
coming up